I'm a huge fan thank you brother I love
entrepreneurship thank you advice do you
have for 12 year old who wants to go
into building to go into business yes
who wants to start a business start a
business yes that is the answer even the
way you positioned I love
entrepreneurship self-awareness is the
game you need to make sure that you're
an actual entrepreneur because at this
age a lot of the entrepreneurs I know
they're selling something they're not
overthinking it maybe you're just a
brilliant executive you need to be very
thoughtful that you're not putting
entrepreneurship on a pedestal do you
really want to build a business do you
want to sell stuff like you get excited
about that well then you need to start
doing it man yes
do you understand yeah don't put it on a
pedestal that it's cool I like Shark
Tank I like garyvee I don't think that's
cool you need to listen to what you
really want to do
there's no I don't know what I want to
sell there's too many things I want to
do do you understand yeah and you need
to figure that part out thank you so
much you got it